so I I was saying I want to put do other
in the right perspective because the a
lot of the mistakes you are making in
gaining the most benefit from it is that
you're working with the modern self
defense model so the first thing is
obviously you've made a competition of
it and you're trying to win and you're
trying not to lose so you already
entered a kind of mind that does not
lend itself to G wasn't did you get the
fright right from the get-go right when
you adopt that mind because of the
body-mind connection you've pretty much
guaranteed you are not going to get the
most out of this type of training
so we have to not be thinking in terms
of Naga is supposed to be the winner or
hookah is trying to make me lose and I
have to as Nagas try to avoid that we're
not even supposed to be thinking in
terms of a kind of any kind of
preference and avoidance even beyond the
competition of two people so for example
oftentimes you find that this particular
UK keeps creating a certain energy print
that causes you to keep doing it evening
I'll get it over and over and over and
over again and then what happens in your
mind is you go I've done that technique
five times I got to stop doing that
technique and now you have a repulsion
to that technique and you have an
attraction to something else how what
was wrong with eating me nugget if it
was matching the energy that you were
dealing with do you see that
because what Jia was a training is is
really a kind of playing with energy and
the unfortunate part is that our
thinking happens in a kind of narrative
manner we like to think that there's a
beginning the middle and an end the door
and you're actually having as you're
training this kind of hero fantasy which
goes in in sync with that competition
that you're trying to win and try not to
lose so you go okay here comes my
attacker now that's the start of it and
then you do the middle part of this
movie you're in and then you find the
ending which ends with you on the
mountaintop with your arms and the fuse
right really what's happening is it's
just the nature of the the way that we
have to practice that it appears that
there's a beginning and an ending but
some systems work with energy
transference and they don't they don't
have a disconnect that allows a beginner
practitioner to feel that oh this is a
new beginning so when we we might do
some you know some of the more the knife
flows or we might do some trapping
drills and where does it stop and start
you just keep going with the energy
transference right until the teacher
tells you okay switch roles or switch
partners and and then you keep working
that drill
why is that important I think that's
important because one you're really
deluding yourself if you think that you
are going to win a G Wazza and then more
so that if you do win that G was it that
that means you're now ready to fight it
doesn't mean that there's no one-to-one
direct correlation between GU aza and
fighting there is a skill in G us that
you need to fight people bigger than you
stronger than you
what is that skill this kind of energy
transference this kind of capacity to
repeatedly neutralize energy transfer it
in a direction that strategically
advantageous to you and at a
disadvantage to the other person right
and the more you do that the longer
you're practicing that the better so in
fact when you when you kind of throw
okay it's it's almost a very poor
training model because you know you're
not really doing it until they come back
in again right
so there's this kind of double-edged
sword with the delusion the G wuzza is
some kind of sparring and a treatment
like sparring and then the negative side
effect that you're not working on the
skill that you ultimately want which is
this energy transformation energy
neutralization do you understand
so if if I'm trying to win I'm trying to
beat my okay what do you usually see
what you don't see energy neutralization
you don't see energy transformation you
see it overpowering
right and overpowering assumes that I
can overpower my attacker it's the exact
opposite goal I wanted I wanted a skill
set that allows me to remain largely
viable against stronger bigger people
what are you practicing a skillset that
only works on weak or slower people so
if you're going to do gu aza and you're
going to try to go as fast as you can
and as hard as you can and push through
every obstacle it's really a waste and
you're going to do that if you're trying
to win you over every time I've never
not seen I've never seen somebody who
wants to win jus Wazza and then it's
actually doing
something different than overpowering so
the points that I'm trying to make as I
interrupt your own reps is one have look
how effortless it's supposed to be -
right
hey why did you stop grabbing me because
you thought I wasn't ready just grab me
I'm going to deal with that energy right
it's not what was that unfair is that
what it was and probably for a
competition it would be unfair but for
an energy transference energy
neutralization drill that's going to
give me a better opportunity to continue
to develop that skill right because that
I add my number of years and hours of
training you grabbing my wrist as though
this is goofy right I I want you to run
into me from the back and see what I you
know what I mean with the other guy in
front of me and know where to go and I'm
pressed against the wall I I want to see
that I also in the in the interruptions
that effortless thing okay what what is
actually there what is there spiritually
and what is not there spiritually when
I've made a competition out of it when
I'm trying to overpower or you can ask
what is there when you're competition
you have a competition and you're trying
to overpower the ego fear non acceptance
there's no way you can really not want
to lose without those things there
there's no way and the irony is that as
you as you practice this non acceptance
because you're practicing this avoidance
because you're practicing this
preference because you're want to win
right as you're doing all that strangely
you actually worse off your technique is
actually less effective right you you've
foreseen things and you can tell you're
forcing so you can your technique gets
stalled on the bigger people in your
class or you get really tired you're
getting really tired in an energy
neutralization drill think about that
how much are you heading in the right
direction if you're prematurely
exhausting yourself if the drill was hey
make this about energy neutralization
you should be rested
so we have this it's the same exact
problem from my perspective when we're
doing the net was a-- says same exact
problem rather than learning the craft
the art as the masters of old you're
stuck on this short goal so as i said
you can do setups you can set people up
right you can shoot for the armbar and
wait for the counter an eighth and then
you know hit the triangle but it it just
works on idiots or you can find a way to
have communion with the now and the
partner to where you can't get out of it
I can tell you what I'm doing and you're
not going to get out of it that's what I
hope to point out with how effortless
does that looking
and you is adesh II when you're doing
this energy transference energy
neutralization training it's got to be
something that you chase after and it
has to be prioritized over trying to win
G wasn't you can't let yourself think of
G was a as sparring it's not now if you
order if you were to buy my perspective
and you are trying to work on energy
transference energy neutralization of a
spontaneous kind what drill would you
come up with you would not discover a
better drill would you find that skill
set in sparring hmm probably not
there's too much else going on too much
else going on let's just work on this
right so it's not the end all of your
training but you still have a
responsibility to make sure you're
practicing it correctly so that you
don't rely on setups and favourite moves
because those only work on idiots and
that's from the Marshall perspective
from the spiritual perspective it's even
worse because that's a federal mind that
is a preference seeking mind that is a
resistant mind an avoidance mind it is
spiritually immature
so it's even more so that when you train
in these more live environments that you
really pay attention to the actual goals
of the training that you are self
observant to see if your pride is
getting the hold of you and it's making
you do things that you shouldn't be
doing I don't know how else to you know
I can only tell you that I can point out
the logic of it to you
I can even tease you but you have to be
the one to go I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
stop doing that I'm gonna stop trying to
win gee was I right and strangely even
things like doing it even now get five
times in a row yeah you're not gonna do
that anymore
strangely strangely that doesn't tend to
happen because especially when you allow
three or four okay they don't all talk
the same because they can't come in at
the same angle and the same time and the
my is all different that's why you get
so many different variations of stuff
you've never even done before seen
before
so kihon is is includes the same kind of
thing you are by architectural design
supposed to find the way of taking this
prescribed energy transfer it you know
neutralize it transfer it but because
it's been prescribed it misses something
it misses exactly what you guys are
struggling with and that is that
spiritual side and if you look at your
own training for example you can do
kokyo if it's if we're doing keyhole
walls like Coco Hall you can make that
work nine out of ten times you're not
gonna push on their neck and you know I
mean you're gonna you're gonna find the
blend and get it to go but GU Aza all of
a sudden we start shoving people's faces
instead of letting them in why is that
because there is that there is that
spiritual component there is a
requirement to not have an avoiding
resisting spirit to accept what is
happening is necessary to begin a
neutralization think about it if you're
practicing a preference thing and you're
then practicing an avoidance then you
are cops in a rejection in some way
there's something wrong with this energy
and you need it to stop now you need to
go here now instead of going I'm gonna
let it go where it wants to go till it
stops until it disappears do you see and
then that's where I find the tsuki and
the Kazushi
then I find the shukaku I'm not dropped
my weight in the shukaku and presto
magico everything happened and I didn't
didn't do anything but let it happen
that's not a purely technical thing that
is not a purely architectural thing that
is primarily a spiritual thing take
those same descriptors and apply them
outside of your Aikido class this crap
is Haiti is getting me the boss and the
job and my family right if you can
experience all that with no repulsion to
it with an acceptance to let it run its
course until it just is neutralized
that's not a technical thing it's a
spiritual thing
this is all done with invisible
intangible things and that is at the
heart of G awesome so when we're doing G
was a and in essence we change this to a
kind of poor-man's Kiyomasa
then I just reset over and over really
fast you get it that there's no point to
doing gu aza what I want to do instead
is do G was a learn Jia was a and then
go back and do Mikey one like it is G
awesome we have it backwards right now
we're trying to make our Chi our G you
like it's kihon and we wanted the other
way around
we want our GU was it to be DiSpirito
practice and that's exactly what I take
back
two key one and then there is no
difference kihon is GU GU is GU we don't
want kihon ski on and GU is keel and we
don't want that so as I said you guys
have come a long way but you know we're
not really freezing
remember the freezing days and you get
pushed into the wall you remember that
okay that's not really happening
but we're still forcing and
philosophically structurally the lack of
action is very much the same thing as a
forced action it's not fitting it's not
accepting it's not using what's there
okay
so you have to be the one just like in
net wasa when we're rolling we're not
competing you're doing energy
neutralization energy transformation so
you feel them pulling on your arm or
whatever a give them the freaking arm
see where it takes you
it's very low level to try to save that
arm because some terrible's gonna happen
especially in training there's always a
counter
and you're never going to learn that can
aesthetically if you're always trying to
stop things from happening get yourself
in trouble situations so you learned not
a trouble Situationists only trouble
situation when I try to not get in it
that's when I made it in a trouble
situation before that it's just energy
and everything's energy I can use
everything
so as you guys are going to keep doing
these drills wait okay what
give me a pointer son say all right hey
if something's pushing on you don't keep
pushing on it go back to your basics
harmonize yin and Yan if it's pushing on
you
what is that you and you're young so
what do you do you nor young okay if
there's a void right they have the that
I noticed that a lot of times you guys
have someone sort of off bow it's very
strange how this it gets all jacked up
so the youngest pushing on you then you
push back on the young then they're like
about to fall and you stay yet it's like
take a bigger entry ebay me it Amy how
many times I have to say it Amy hobo
lateral throw hobo what you guys will
not enter into that freaking spa it's
very strange isn't it
right you know how it is
universe is always with us so if
you can keep entering hey keep freaking
entering we're just pushing on you
tenkan and you don't need to ten cons
for anything let's just make that
footnote right here so if I don't need
to because if I ten con then they're yen
now they were young I tank on there now
yen I can now enter don't get confused
I keep ten Carney ten kind out that's my
Anakin Skywalker I'll just try spinning
that's always good right no it's not
because now you're just doing crap over
and over and really why are you doing
that because you're stuck and really why
are you stuck because you're trying to
avoid something so you don't keep doing
two three four
you can't keep expecting people to run
around you just cuz we said it's an
energy transference drill okay
you see 110 con you'll have your you'll
have your Y in space you know what
you'll go through it got it so but start
there so yeah okay what else do I know
well let them in let them in stop
stopping them let them in you're eating
me you're young reversal is entirely
conditioned by your Y in space if my
Tsuyoshi my shuffle step has a range of
six inches of penetration that's gonna
mean more if I let them in further then
if I stop them and keep them out stop
them and keep them out you might have
two feet you might be like a six foot
something and you can get two feet of
fujiyoshi it probably won't be enough
you have to let them in and that takes
us right back to the beginning not
letting them in is resisting is
rejecting is avoiding is preferring let
them in
who cares if they come in you're not
trying to win you're trying to transfer
energy so if I'm trying to neutralize it
to let it complete itself if I stop it
I'm contesting it so you have to let
them in tell yourself in your head
something that helps you I used to
actually tell myself welcome welcome
like I was opening my front door welcome
to my house I thought I would do the mic
vampire voice welcome I played the
vampire in high school welcome in my
head I would have that because I could
feel myself trying to stop them you see
so it helps well welcome and open the
tension now get up open the cookie hole
up right that way they're not standing
straight up when you know you're trying
to accelerate them first of all how many
times have I said there is no freaking
step backwards back break fall that's a
beginner back break fall all falls on
someone's back is them going forward
well we're not doing kilo and it's not
slow it's Jesus so bring those people
forward let them go forward you don't
accelerate someone words and then they
fall you let them forward and you stop
their head and their feet keep going
forward so try to let them in so so far
I'm not going to push on what's pushing
on me I'm going to match into young
young to Yin if I'm being pushed I'm
going to ten Khan if I can I'm gonna
inter I'm gonna inter as far as
I can and I'm going to let them in I'm
going to welcome them in I'm not going
to try to stop them I'm not going to win
GE was a I'm going to experiment and
play with energy I want that skill